here Bernie dropped out today yes I
think the media is very biased you just
found that out huh I did and that is
terrible news because I I wanna vote a
thing I can vote for Joe Biden I don't
think I can he let he's been dead in
three years he's also utterly incapable
of speaking
he just has got some dementia yeah I'm
actually worried about do you remember
you you might not be I don't know why I
do I think it was cuz it DC Follies it
was a old kind of puppet Ron TV show but
do you remember in the mid-80s Joe Biden
ran for president he dropped out had to
drop out because he's cheated later I
cheated on like a lot of yeah that's
else that's right something even
plagiarism scale and it wasn't like
they've got it all wrong they've got oh
he's like [ __ ] I'm screwed I'm out I'm
out yeah and no one brings that up I was
caught for plagiarism
did you ever see what he was like and I
just wanna thank my sis are my wife and
it's his sister yeah you just he's just
he's you know some of those things are
you just making so many species over and
over and you're exhausted at the end of
the day you're gonna [ __ ] up and the
media loves to catch it but I don't he's
always been considered in Washington a
bit of a blowhard right and there's a
type of [ __ ] up to like we all with
everything that happy if you're a
professional MMA fighter even if you're
[ __ ] Cain Velasquez it is prime you
make mistakes but it's the way certain
people make mistakes that you got you go
okay well that just that's what happens
Obama made gaffes but when Obama was
making gaffes he's a scratch that boom
back in it long smooth as it and Clinton
locked in um Joe Biden is like you're
watching his brain break yeah you know
yeah you're like he might just be all
that suffering from some kind of it all
happen percent there's a glitch going on
up there I did he can't be President
when I worry about that I do try I would
have voted for Bernie man I really would
have too much of a socialist was not
gonna it's rough and I think I actually
heard you Brian bring it up on JRE it's
a fact like let's lest we forget the man
honeymooned in Moscow yeah I mean that
you know I thinks Bernie Bernie is a
good man I think Bernie
believes I believe he believes what he
says he says what he believes yeah and I
appreciate that so there's an
authenticity to Bernie I thought I liked
him when I listened to him on JRE I
loved my problem with Bernie is just
that he is
he speaks in terms of right and wrong
and morality god bless him god bless him
about everybody deserves healthcare and
everything else the who's gonna pay for
it is secondary and I do think he has
tremendous faith in a centralized
authority of state government federal
government and that that is more
efficient than the marketplace I don't
think he's ever lived in a marketplace
right I don't think he understands how
the marketplace works and viscerally and
and and so for me as somebody who
believes that a decentralization of
authority and and who believes in the
marketplace for the most part capitalism
I just don't I can't have a guy like
that's a great way to put it I always
looked at Bernie - I I agree that I
think he's the most altruistic
high-level politician we've had where he
where he's saying believe believes it
it's not enough front he's not thinking
about how how well it tests or how they
talk about what leaves or Denny and the
guys been protesting and standing up for
free speech and and socialist ideas you
know yeah more socialist looking ideas
for [ __ ] 50 years I mean he walk it
like he talk it I like that about Bernie
but every one of his ideas always struck
me as Tweaker ideas
we're like you'll smoke meth and you're
standing recon every few days in a row
you're like dude we could rob a bank
and you're like yes yes that's a great
idea not sleeping just crazy tweaking
balls oh it is a helicopter and an RPG
and a [ __ ] Porsche and you're
realistically believing this is a good
idea it's you could pull this [ __ ] on
Bernie is like a free college for
everyone tomorrow but there's no plan it
just it's it's nice it's like a loser
it's a great idea because my whole thing
with where I vote for Bernie is I almost
vote for the person more than their
beliefs because it's so tough for them
to really do anything so I vote for the
person yeah he's not gonna Barris the
the United States you know for him to
the tax laws he want to do and all that
stuff that's never gonna get past I had
Trump some credit again
you got to be careful with giving a
president too much credit for
massive economy of US economy but you do
have to say while he was president if
these figures are correct and I've heard
them from several different sources
lowest african-american unemployment
lowest Latin that Latin unemployment in
this country ever and the economy was
gangbusters due until this raising so
you gotta give the guy some credit yeah
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue
oh good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]